so we're only given these two end points
of the diameter of a circle and we want
to write the equation in standard form
which is this form right here HK is the
center of the circle but how do we find
the center just given these two end
points well we're gonna want to use our
midpoint formula which is this one down
here and you can see that it's an
average of the X's and an average of the
Y's so let's go ahead and do that so if
we take two plus eight I'm just adding
the two x-coordinates in dividing by two
and I'm going to take one plus seven
adding the two y-coordinates together in
dividing by two we'll find that middle
point the midpoint so we've got ten
divided by two eight divided by two so
you can see that our midpoint here is
five comma four right five up four
somewhere right into there now what we
want to do is go ahead and put that in
for each and K so that's going to be X
minus five the quantity squared plus y
minus four the quantity squared equals
the radius squared now how do we find
the radius well you can do this two
different ways one way is you can use
the distance formula between the center
and either this endpoint or this
endpoint or you can do what I like to do
which is just to take this equation as
we have it in this form now and just
pick one of the endpoints that's a point
on our circle and put it in for X and Y
and what we'll do is we'll solve for R
squared so we have 2 minus 5 which is
negative 3 squared plus 1 minus 4 which
is also negative 3 squared equals our
radius squared so this is 9 plus 9 which
is 18 which equals R squared now you
don't need to take the square root of
both sides because we're actually
looking for R squared so let's go ahead
and just put that in for R squared and
you've got the equation of your circle
in standard form if you want to see
another video that I did talking about
finding the equations of circles in
standard form by completing the square
check out the video I did right there
and I'll see over in that video